Euh, Frédéric, vous parliez de pédagogie il y a 1 instant.
Euh, cette étude ifopie du ciel pour le Figaro,
LCI et sud-radio,
euh, elle utilise la méthode du Rolling.
Oui, en 1 mot, c'est c'est quoi 1 méthode de Rolling ?
Alors, le Rolling, c'est 1 sondage permanent,
sondage continue,
on interroge tous les jours 500 personnes,
on publie 1 rapport de forêt sélectoral sur 3 jours,
500+500+500, donc mille-cinq-cents personnes,
et au fur à mesure qu'on avance,
c'est 1 sondage glissant.
On supprime les tiers d'interview,
euh, les. Euh. Plus anciens.
Quand on est sur 1 sondage classique
d'attention de l'autre,
on est sur 1 logique de faux,
de photos, qui se continue.
On attend 1 semaine avant de faire l'enquête,
1 enquête à l'autre.
Là, vu que c'est tous les jours,
on est plutôt sur 1 logique de film.
On va essayer de voir avec des mouvements plutôt doux.
Moi, je me fie toujours dans les enquêtes électorales
des plus 3, des -5, des plus 2.
Quand on regarde, quand on ramène,
c'est brusque,
quand on ramène ces chiffres au corps électoral,
on se dit,
c'est pas possible qu'en d'une semaine à l'autre,
1 Nice perdre 1.000.000 de voix
ou six-cent-mille voix.
Avec le Rolling,
on est sur des mouvements beaucoup plus doux.
C'est dire que les 1 point de plus
du RN sur 1 période très courte
veulent dire quelque chose.
Il y a la, le mécontentement intérieur des français,
la situation de la dette,
cette série. Terrible. En terme d'insécurité,
de logique, dislamisation
à Montpellier,
euh, à Bordeaux,
oui, tout ça compte dans le vote des français.
Est-ce qu'il y a des des
thèmes qui s'imposent dans cette campagne ?
Alors il est trop tôt pour le dire.
Mais en tout cas, plus que jamais,
la question sociale,
la question du pouvoir d'achat compte, la question
la question climatique
et la question de l'école. Avec, comme je disais,
1 lien avec, euh, l'insécurité.
Ce qui s'est passé à Viry Châtillon
a fortement choqué les français.
C'est 1 des sujets dont les Français ont le plus parlé.
Dans notre baromètre ifofidusial pour match
et sud-radio, on a pour l'instant,
et c'est ça qui est gênant pour la majorité
présidentielle,
c'est des thématiques intérieures qui s'imposent,
plus que peut-être l'action de l'Union européenne.
Et puis autres éléments qui accrédit
1 sanction possible
d'email Macron.
Notre enquête publiée ce matin sur les 2 ans de son
élection,
le jugement positif à son égard, sur les dimensions
internationales et européennes
s'est effondré.
De presse de 15 points
entre deux-mille-vingt-et-un
et deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Le parti présidentiel en mauvaise posture.
Alors 1 liste qui pourrait potentiellement en profiter,
c'est l'emmener par François Xavier Bellami.
Et il est républicain.
Sauf que dans euh, ce sondage, euh.
Il faut fudicier pour le Figaro,
LC et sud de radio, dans ce Rolling,
euh donc ce sondage, euh quotidien, euh. Et bien
les républicains restent à 8,5%.
C'est 1 peu le le même score qu'aux élections,
qu'aux dernières.
Élections européennes en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Oui, ils sont même à 8. Euh, aujourd'hui. Y a 1 petit euh.
Alors y a quand-même des éléments qui sont plutôt, euh.
Encourageant. Premièrement,
pour l'instant, même si on est sur 2 points d'écart,
le match avec en conquête
est plutôt tourne à l'avantage
euh. De François Xavier benamy.
Deuxièmement, il est beaucoup plus.
Qui est la liste de marion-marie-jér Le Pen qui est à
6%, qui est à 6%,
qui a 1 score aussi assez intéressant
pour 1 parti très jeune.
Le fait de d'être très proche de
l'étihage présidentiel
d'Harry Zemmour n'est pas 1 mauvais
euh. Résultat, 7:6.
Deuxièmement,
François Zelia belémie est plus connu des français.
Par rapport à deux-mille-dix-neuf,
il y a toujours 1 image plutôt bienveillante.
Cette image que j'ai appelé
par le passé d'ailleurs dans le Figaro,
monsieur Smith
océna, qui a apporté renouvellement,
de la fraîcheur,
1 certaine sincérité.
Et puis, 1 peu comme d'autres têtes de liste,
il est sortant,
il a des choses à dire sur son bilan,
il peut essayer de montrer
pour faire revenir chez lui des électeurs.
Tenter par la conquête,
voir tenter par le RN,
dire, voilà ce que j'ai fait pendant 5 ans. Et puis,
qu'est-ce qui avait coûté cher en deux-mille-dix-neuf ?
Rappelez-vous, il faut-il faut être honnête,
les sondages,
notamment se divordent, le mettaient à 11, 12%.
Même en fin de campagne, il a fini à 8 et demi pour 100.
Mais c'était 1 grosse déception en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Bah tout. À fait, il y a eu 1 vote utile
vers la liste de la majorité
présidentielle
pourrait, pour empêcher que le RN soit en tête.
La contenue de l'écart entre le RN et la majorité,
contenu d'autre part de
l'émetteur Macron
qui est beaucoup plus abîmé qu'en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Sans doute que ce risque
de perdre d'électeur de droite
vers la majorité
est nettement plus faible.
Même si quand on regarde les pages de notre au ligne,
on se dit quand-même que la part d'électeur âgé qui,
ils choisissent la liste des républicains
est trop faible,
à peine 9%, quand on sait que le le, je dirais le le,
le centre de gravité et la le le,
le socle électoral
d'un partie droite comme 1 républicain,
ce sont les personnes âgées.
Là, il y a des marches de progression réelle.
On parlait de,
vous parliez de
la liste reconquête emmenée par miroir maréchal,
qui est donc est estimé à à à 6% dans votre sondage.
Est-ce qu'on sait à qui elle prend des voix finalement,
clairement, elle prend des voix à la droite.
Marion-maréchal,
arrive à prendre des électeurs de Valérie Pécresse,
elle prend 1 peu de 1 peu,
1 peu
d'électeur de Marine Le Pen, deux-mille-vingt-deux.
Mais surtout le risque,
et c'est ça qui est assez intéressant.
Maintenant, marichelle arrive par son équation,
euh, personnelle, arrivée à 6%,
elle prend des personnes qui n'ont pas voté à la
par exemple, elle perd aussi beaucoup
du côté de Jordan bardela dans Le Rolling du jour,
il y a presque plus de 40% des lecteurs Zemmour,
deux-mille-vingt-deux, qui choisissent la liste. Euh.
Bardela. Il y a 1 vrai danger de fuite.
Peut-être pas 1 logique de votre utile. Les français,
beaucoup, ont intériorisé que
Jordan Bardella,
je vais peut-être prendre 1 risque,
mais y a peu de chance d'être délogé de la 1ère place,
même si le neuf/06, c'est extrêmement loin.
La campagne va commencer, vraiment,
on le disait dans quelques semaines,
voilà, il faut être bien sur présent.
Mais c'est vrai que y a 1 danger
de voir des électeurs d'Éric Zemmour se dire,
bah, l'avenir, euh. La projection euh.
Positive sur deux-mille-vingt-sept.
C'est moi, marion-maréchal, aueric Zemmour,
que Jordan Bardella,
euh, Frédéric Dhabi, il y a aussi, euh.
Toute 1 série de petites listes.
Alors c'est le cas pour euh.
Tous les scrutins, bien sûr. Mais euh. Euh.
C'est le cas pour euh.
Ces élections européennes,
euh. Par exemple, l'alliance rural
nouvelle donne,
elle se retrouve aussi dans votre sondage.
Euh. Très franchement,
ces listes, est-ce qu'elles ont 1 chance, euh.
De passer ce fameux seul de 5% ?
Alors vous ne faites pas de prédiction.
Oui, on entend bien, mais
pour le moment, est-ce que.
Est-ce qu'il y a 1 dynamique dans ces petites listes ?
Alors pour l'instant, non,
c'est petit, 5%,
c'est difficile d'atteindre, je pense,
plutôt 3% qui permettent 1 remboursement,
euh. Des frais.
On se souvient par exemple,
en deux-mille-dix-neuf, que le parti, euh.
Animaliste avait temps gentil De mémoire, les 2 et demi,
3%, il est pour l'instant 1 et demi pour 100.
Il y a des listes connues, la liste, euh upr qui s'est,
euh. À plusieurs reprises, euh.
Faites présenter,
il y a la liste de nouvelles donnes,
euh. Hmm. Pierre larotero est 1 est 1 sortant,
il était-il était avec avec Raphaël luxemann
en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Nobeldon est 1 marque assez connue.
Mais pour l'instant,
c'est vrai que dans 1 moment où les Français sont pas
polarisés sur ce Christian,
c'est liste peine à exister.
Et beaucoup, dans notre Rolling,
y en a au -5 ou 6 et on teste,
on les teste encore. Pas toutes
sont entre 0 et 1%.
Alors 1 petit point de pédagogie pour nos auditeurs
et téléspectateurs,
personne n'a 0,
mais 0 veut dire qu'on est en dessous de 0, 5%,
ce qui veut dire quelque chose de de très très faible.
1 toute dernière question, Frédéric Dhabi,
euh,
dans ce sondage, il faut plus du ciel. Pour le Figaro,
LCI et sud-radio,
on a parlé et on a vu le.
On a parlé du résultat
actuel dans votre sondage, de gluxman,
de François Xavier Bellamy,
les 2 ces derniers jours,
ces dernières semaines,
ils essaient quelque part de ressusciter
clivage gauche droite.
Est-ce que ça, c'est stratégique pour eux ?
Ah bah, c'est 1 très très bonne, euh,
stratégie. On y a eu 1 débat de très haute tenue,
très cordial, très courtois.
Si ça faisait du bien par rapport. À d'autres débats,
je donnerai pas de nom,
euh. Chez vos confrères de BFM, je crois.
Euh dimanche, euh hier,
dimanche dernier,
euh. C'est vrai que recré du clivage gauche droite,
c'est aussi, euh. Associé.
Prendre en étant la liste de Valérie,
euh. Ayée, qui a 1 source de droite,
1 source de gauche de plus en plus, euh
réduite, et c'est faire revenir
des électeurs dans ce choix bida qui a quand-même
structuré la République en France depuis,
euh. Le début de la 5e République,
et qui peine à. De reprendre le contrôle,
même si la liste, euh
luxemann est clairement,
non pas en dynamique, mais en tête à gauche.
Et François Xavier Benjamin est plutôt 1 score
intéressant,
moins élevé qu'en deux-mille-dix-neuf pour le moment,
mais qui est plutôt qui a,
qui est plutôt porteur de promesse
dans la perspective du 09/06.
Donc en s'opposant l'un à l'autre,
évidemment, ils
potentiellement bien sûr, peuvent gagner des voix chacun.
Euh. Dossier, euh. En l'objectif, on l'imagine.
Merci beaucoup Frédéric David, merci.
Je rappelle que les élections européennes,
c'est donc du 6 au 09/06 prochain,
on continuera à les observer avec vous.
Je rappelle que
vous êtes le
directeur opinion de l'institut de sondage Ifop.
Merci encore